when was it that
you announced that you you were retiring
and yeah it was honestly it was like
i think it was like two weeks before
that my last album came out no pressure
um and yeah i'm just tired of all the
[ __ ]
you know and i know you know how that is
just in general with entertainment you
know when you're hot people love you
when you're
not there you know nobody's calling or
this or that or whatever and
i just i'm sick of [ __ ]
like i love hip-hop hip-hop is so
beautiful um but the [ __ ] boy culture
around it of like click baits and
um everyone wants to kill each other and
you know as far as like beefing rappers
once again not everyone's like this
hip-hop isn't based on that hip-hop is
based on unity
on expression um and
i think i was just kind of at a place
where it's like all these like
gatekeepers
i felt like i hadn't been accepted by
them and yet you got
cats like wu-tang and nas and you know
all my heroes love me so i'm like why is
it that i'm trying to
and then what i realized is without even
knowing it i had kind of like
just fallen on my ass into this
mainstream
world um and it just wasn't fun so i
didn't want to do it anymore
and i got my little boy little bobby and
he's amazing and i'm just kind of
focused on that i still make music
though
literally surrounded there's like six
guitars next to me and like mpc beat
machines and [ __ ]
nice what does retiring look like though
if you're still gonna do music
i think it's like i don't i
one thing as i get older so i'm 30 now
everything for me
um probably up into the last year it was
always fine
finite like like uh this is it
you know like i'm doing an album this is
it there's only going to be 16 songs on
it that's it
and it's again i haven't even made one
yet or you know i'm only i'm going to do
this and i'm going to do that
or whatever now as i get older i'm just
kind of like go with the flow so
you know there's some people's like oh
he's not going to stay retired or he's
not going to this or he's not going to
that
but i guess for me it's more so like the
[ __ ] of the industry is what i'm
leaving
and i'm kind of tired of rap i love rap
music
i love rappers i love modern rap i love
old school rap i
i really love it all i'm tired of it
because
rap is one a bunch of braggadocio not
all rap but not all my rap but a lot of
it is founded in here's why i'm the best
better than you got more money you've
got this and the [ __ ] is like
systemically ingrained in us
to kind of like boast and and whatever
the case may be
so even though i would consider myself a
conscious um
rapper sorry for the long-winded answer
even though
even though i would consider myself yeah
like a very conscious rapper who
speaks on a lot of you know life [ __ ] um
i still have fallen down that rabbit
hole of like
a bit of uh i wouldn't even necessarily
say
like materialism because i'm not really
a materialistic person
yeah exactly but i think um thanks ace
yeah i think um i think it's
i kind of just fell out of love with me
doing it
so you know even on these songs that i'm
making now it's like i'm singing on them
um and there's some raps
i remember i was i was in this studio
with my homies the other day
and we made this crazy ass song it
sounds like kind of like some like tame
and polish it
and and i'm looking around and i'm like
i did this whole thing i'm singing i'm
hitting these high notes i'm so proud of
myself for pushing myself and
trying different learning the [ __ ]
guitar but not like learning it like a
[ __ ] like where i'm on stage like yeah
i know this one chord but like i'm
really going in you know
and um there's a section i'm like yo we
know it sounds so dope
somebody rapped right here who could we
get to rap and then like
six people in the studio just look at me
and i was like oh yeah that's right
i do that yeah dude